good morning Hank it's Friday earlier
this week I was like I got attacked by a
baby well Hank in the intervening few
days I have as you can see been attacked
by a giant baby so I'm just sitting
around and I see this giant baby pulling
himself on the ground crawling toward me
and crawling toward me and then BAM
giant baby attack or maybe I fell off my
bike and broke a rib anyway Hank I don't
think I've ever shown you my backyard
which as you can see looks astonishingly
like Sonoma California mount one again
that hurts
are you okay fine it was slippery it was
wet I just shut down that like a like a
like I shoot her down a chute thing all
of my brother 2.0 recreates in moment so
Hank and I here in Sonoma California we
are here for dad's 60th birthday party
dad come on end for the dad is not here
because mom broke her ankle and so mom
and dad couldn't come so we are
celebrating dad's 60th birthday without
them anyway mom we love you and sorry
that you are not here with us John
almost couldn't come because he hurt
himself very badly we already covered
everyone covered so today's video is
going to be a quick one because we have
to go do stuff that honors our dad on
his 60th birthday at wineries exactly
and also because we want to go inside
and enjoy the amazing place that we have
rented that mom and dad can't enjoy with
its amazing window shades of amazing and
also with the world's quietest fridge
you're very impressed by the fridge it's
so quiet I like the barbecue you could
you could like have an entire pig on it
okay show but last night Hank and I were
talking about the fact that we both have
thousands and thousands of outstanding
friend requests on Facebook because
Facebook believes that you can only have
5,000 friends yes Facebook does not
understand the internet it does not
understand nerdfighteria so our solution
is that we have changed our Facebook
pages to pages that can have more than
5,000 friends so now if you want to be
friends with us you
and link in the dooblydoo and lastly
even though I have a broken rib have I
mentioned that to you Hank
you have mentioned it to me the worst
which is worth coughing or hiccuping
last night I got the hiccups and it was
like torture you made me laugh what was
the joke I can't remember
no it wasn't something we can tell
nerdfighters hold on I'm gonna pause the
camera Hank's gonna re tell me the joke
and then I'll tell you if we can tell it
we can't tell you even though I have a
broken rib and I was attacked by a giant
baby we are thinking about doing some
exercises while we here over the weekend
but we need your exercise suggestions
specifically nerd exercises as I just
recently had an idea that's a stretch
called I've dropped something behind the
desk and it's like a it's I think it
might be a zip drive I don't even know
why I still have that thing give your
phone in your pocket no why
when Hank I will see you on Monday